it is an interesting concept one that
can be controversial Public Health
vending machines designed to stop
infections among IV drug users Nevada
the first state in the U.S to implement
Implement them back in 2017. all right
so how does it work and how effective
are they in keeping people alive Madison
Kimbrough join us in the studio tonight
stop by the Southern Nevada Health
District earlier today where one of
those machines is located she joins us
now with more details yes thank you
Denise now these machines not only offer
clean syringes but several other health
kits to minimize the risk of disease and
infection I spoke to officials with the
program behind the vending machines who
shared how they are benefiting the
community
when I was in my Heyday of using this
wasn't an option
so pretty much if we wanted syringes to
use we would have to go to a pharmacy
and get lucky Spencer costella is
talking about the lengths he would go
through to get high he's eight years
clean and now a peer recovery support
specialist from syringe kits with clean
needles to hormone kits first aid and
safe sex kits these machines provide a
variety of harm reduction products
geared towards people who use drugs and
one of the biggest items is naloxone and
opioid medication that can help reverse
and overdose
these Public Health vending machines
first rolled out in 2017 with Nevada
being the first state to carry them in
the country Jessica Johnson Senior
Health educator with the Southern Nevada
Health District says with the increase
in fatal overdoses in Clark County she's
seen the positive effects these machines
can have we measured the impact of the
naloxone being distributed from these
vending machines and on our overdose
rate and we're able to see a reduction
the vending machines really stand on the
shoulders of over 40 years of research
of syringe Services programs that look
at the positive benefits of these types
of programs that help to reduce
someone's substance use help to get them
connected with care for those interested
you can sign up either online or in
person at the health district or any
other location you will receive an
identifying number and a swipe card and
then once approved you'll be able to
access any of the five vending machines
across the valley
and the five active machines in Las
Vegas see an average of about 500
transactions a month we will have a full
list of machine locations attached to
this story up on our website Brian